The answer here is almost depressing.
Now we can handle a maximum input size of 36 even though we have a 100 times speedup,
and the argument is basically the same as before.
Again, you compare this number her for n=30 to this number here
and then see when this one gets larger than this one over here.
And that is why it's so important to understand algorithms and improve algorithms
because if you do any optimizations that are a constant factor even if it's a huge constant factor,
it doesn't really increase the performance of your algorithm
if you're dealing with exponential time algorithms.
So you really have to dive down and understand your algorithm and then improve it.